there have been very few consequences
for Donald Trump during his presidency
for all of the horrible things he's done
and by this I mean the bad policies the
ignorant and ridiculous statements the
embarrassing actions on the geopolitical
stage the lack of decorum the corseting
of the political discourse all of it
right I mean all of it all of it there
have been very few if any consequences
now the most immediate and impactful
consequence there could be would be just
voting Donald Trump out in November of
2020 we've heard from more and more
farmers I told you about this last week
who were clearly indirectly now saying
we are getting crushed and we know why
it's because of Donald Trump's tariffs
this is Donald Trump's fault that our
businesses are imploding and the markets
in which we operate are falling apart
that being said I asked the question
last week will those farmers actually
hold Trump accountable by voting for
somebody else next year you can be a
lifelong Republican farmer that is angry
at Trump for his tariffs and for
destroying your business but you might
still be unveiled unwilling to vote for
a Democrat in November of 2020 we have
to wait and see what voters more broadly
are thinking about Donald Trump and the
economy may bow abode well for the left
in 2020 or it may not what I mean by
that is there's a new poll from Harvard
Cape's Harris which is sort of positive
a majority of voters say if we have a
recession in the next year we will blame
Trump more than anyone else
and most people are worried that indeed
there will be a recession in the next
six months now humans are notoriously
bad at predicting when the next
recession is going to be economists
included we know every day we are one
day closer to the next one because
that's how the system works but by and
large we're not good at predicting
exactly when we are going to have a
recession sometimes we don't even
realize we're in one until we've been in
it for a little bit that being said 57%
of Americans would blame Trump more than
the Federal Reserve or anyone else if
the United States were to enter a
recession by the end of the year 62% of
Americans say they are somewhat or very
concerned that there will be a recession
in the next six months remember that
old trump has been insisting that
anything bad that happens in the economy
is the Federal Reserve's fault of course
the Federal Reserve is led by the person
that he selected to lead it that's
rarely mentioned when he talks about
that on tariffs sixty-three percent of
Americans believed that the tariffs are
hurting the United States more than
China seventy-four percent of Americans
believe that it is American consumers
not China that pays for the tariffs now
that's true I'm actually shocked that 74
percent of Americans understand this
because Donald Trump has done a good job
to the extent that you need to do a good
job to convince ignorant Trumpets of
saying it's China who pays the tariffs
even though of course it is ultimately
American consumers passed the long down
from American companies and
manufacturers that are paying those
tariffs so all of this looks great right
people understand it's American
consumers paying the tariffs people
understand Trump is to blame people
understand if we have a recession Trump
would be more responsible than anybody
else but then the question is will the
people blaming Trump for the recession
vote for a Democrat in November of 2020
and it is the same question that we have
about Republican farmers just because
you accurately correctly precisely blame
Donald Trump for tariffs destroying an
economy doesn't mean all of a sudden
that a religious right Midwestern er is
going to go out and vote for a Democrat
so the strategy I've outlined before
there will be some disaffected Trumpets
because we have a country of 340 million
people some disaffected Trumpets are
going to go and vote for a Democrat
great we'll take it
some disaffected Trumpets are going to
stay home and not vote at all that also
helps us assuming that we can get out
our base but none of this counts as a
strategy we must get our base out that's
it as far as the economic stuff we do
actually have some tools that are
disposable to try to mitigate how bad
whenever the upcoming recession it's
coming at some point we have tools that
we can use to mitigate the seriousness
of the upcoming recession we can tax the
wealthy through ink
capital gains through inheritance taxes
through increasing top income brackets
we know that that's a tool that can be
used is there the political will to do
it that's a different question we can do
infrastructure infrastructure spending
to soften a recession to create jobs to
improve communities we can look at doing
something with student loan debt and
medical debt to free up disposable
income for people to try to push back
against the effects of a recession we
can deal with the cost of housing and
the rising cost of living to put more
disposable income in people's pockets so
each of these is a big project that
requires a lot of discussion but the
point is we now have the 2008 recession
as another case study as in terms of
helping us know what tools that we have
at our disposal can lessen or soften the
effect of a recession is Donald Trump
willing to use any of those tools it's
not clear but in the meantime we can say
it's good that people will correctly
blame Trump most if we are to have a
recession in the next six to twelve
months because that is where the blame
should be we actually have specific
economic policy that we can tie to it
and then the broader question becomes as
we are now 14 months out from the 2020
election will that blame translate not
just into saying you blame Trump but
into actually going to the ballot box
and saying you know on some social
issues I don't agree with these
Democrats or whoever it is that
ultimately is the nominee but for the
good of the economy I'm going to vote
for a Democrat that is the big question
mark and that's what I want to hear from
you about will disaffected trumpets to
any significant degree vote for
Democrats or are they more likely to
just stay home or even vote for Trump
with the caveat that they don't like
everything he's been doing let me know
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show and make
sure you're following us on twitch TV
slash David Pakman four live streams a
several times per week as of late hope
to see you on one of them
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom / pakman Linkous is a
great service that I use all the time
what they do is they take thousands of
the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out
soccer na mcc's by Simon Cooper we do
have after all the World Cup going on
recently we also have been talking about
BS jobs and there is a great new book of
BS jobs by David Graeber which I
listened to on blinka they're constantly
adding new books to the platform you
will never run out of fascinating and
critically acclaimed books to enjoy and
our audience can get a 7 day free trial
by going to blink accom slash Pakman if
you're watching on YouTube I'm putting a
link in the video description and after
the free trial if you'd like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
that's be li NK is t.com /p a que mas